hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Dan Seibert
hello we're gonna review the trailer
today for the Elder Scrolls online
the confrontation cinematic trailer -
long ass trailer so why dog anymore it's
only seven minutes okay
Percy's sexual themes blow my mind
Felix [ __ ] up
that's look incredibly real
someone's about to get wrecked
the
this is the pantsuit
Oh
Oh
click like rooting for
under God
portage and its while it's saying like
who we supposed to be rooting for just
keeps getting killed
produce mark
in it that you can friend
nice convenient
um I I like these cinematic trailers
because I really appreciate them because
of the fact that they tell stories just
through visual medium like they don't
jam-packed them with dialogue or
something like that I mean so it's nice
to know if you know what's going on but
that fight was really cool because a lot
of the times when I see cinematic
trailers for games especially when
there's a fight scene it's usually just
a bunch of fancy moves I like how the
fight itself had an actual story going
on it also felt like gritty again real
it felt like more of a fight than yes
standards it was like stylish but it was
more grounded in realism I like how it
didn't go down that route of like okay
the big guy he's winning and then every
time he seemed like he was making a
comeback I thought it's gonna be a
traditional fight work the little guy
ends up [ __ ] winning but he doesn't
that kind of surprised me actually that
was like oh I guess he's just dead now
unfortunately it's like killing Jan or
something like yeah the sword dude so it
shows him first and like your first
instinct is oh he's got a messed up
faced he must be the bad guy because
that's what makes yeah movies and
videogames and everything has told us
from day one is like if they got a
messed up face
they're probably a bad guy yeah and he
was like the smaller dude and stuff so I
thought he was gonna be like oh he's the
fast acrobatic one you'll probably win
you know but apparently the slow-moving
tough guys the one that the tough guy
was like armed and yeah white like
silver sword stuff you're like always a
hero but then there was like so much
like emotion in like the little guy yeah
that there was something more to it I'm
just like wait I think he might be good
and I think that the best the big guy
might just be a dick groche we knew all
these guys names yeah and there's that
dude in the in the chair I mean I saw
that coming where he was gonna do
something like magic trick instead a
magic spray today or whatever the [ __ ]
he did it made them I will make this
mace dogs yeah pick a card any card
then it was a cool tease with the girl
because like the girl she puts that guy
out of his misery and then it goes to
the title text but then you see that
like oh she took care of business on the
big do now yeah throws off his mask or
something for a video game character
she's you know she's pretty good-looking
if so it's always cool to play as a hot
girl you know live vicariously through a
hot girls body yeah
you know our know it's like they have a
vagina one day who I think I can arrange
this like I might cost a little bit of
money but I think you can do it I think
I can do it sit back when Elder Scrolls
online was like first introduced to the
world they released the cinematic
trailer with three characters a revert
that were similar it's been a while
since I watched that trailer but I
wonder if it's the same three characters
I could be wrong
what I will say like I've seen a lot of
game trailers but as far as cinematic
graphics go that is some of the best
I've ever seen
yeah now it looked very authentic the
whole time and it's like in this fantasy
world but it was still like this looks
real we live in a very awesome time
where like game trailers can essentially
be short films yeah you know we become a
little immune to graphics but when I was
looking at these graphics I was like
that looks amazing
yeah that's got to the point where like
even I myself I'm like it looks good I'm
not actually like super impressed but I
was looking at this going this is really
impressive graphics anyway guys thanks
for telling us that trailer was out if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects
and you can check out Dan's gaming
channel what we're it's a gaming channel
you've done it again you crack the code
I crack the code and shout outs will
commence soon so go to facebook.com
slash the real reject shout outs where
you can earn yourself a shout out by
saying something interesting yeah tell
us are you gonna get Elder Scrolls
online on
Tamriel unlimited yeah are you a gamer
or you Jewish whatever it is just let us
know what does Jewish have to do that's
interesting huh go mean geez interesting
I suppose what are you racist No why is
it interesting I think it's I think it's
meaning another human beings always
interesting don't put that on me